the war in ukraine overshadowed good
friday observances at the vatican two
women a ukrainian and a russian who
worked together at a rome hospital took
part in pope francis's way of the cross
service
but the meditation they wrote was
scrapped after protest by ukrainian
catholics claimed the war made it
inappropriate
in jerusalem palestinians and israeli
police clashed friday at the al-aqsa
mosque more than 150 worshipers were
injured at the site that is sacred to
jews and muslims it comes as ramadan
coincides with passover and holy week
as chris lipsey reports from odessa
ukraine faith has provided some measure
of comfort for those seeking solace
during war time
after sundown in odessa the celebrations
at the synagogue drown out the air raid
sirens in a war zone carnival masks and
party hats might seem out of place
not to mention clowns and a petting zoo
but this is purim the holiday that
rejoices in the survival of the jews who
in the 5th century bce were marched for
death by a bloodthirsty empire
a timely remembrance says rabbi avraham
wolf who tells the congregation it's
okay to say bad things about putin
tonight he tells me he hasn't eaten or
slept in days but can't show his tears
to shabbat odessa who looks to him for
courage
it's not a freedom a
country like like you can i never
say something and i look down back if
somebody hear me no more freedom
place than ukraine so you feel more free
to be a jew here than anywhere else then
israel i feel here in ukraine the best
the best place in the world i can go i
can say what i think i can say what i
don't think
it's a normal place
at a recent rally in russia vladimir
putin was pushing a very different
reality
praising pro-russian separatists in
ukraine for putting up a rigid barrier
against neo-nazis
he claims are running the country a
rallying cry meant to scare russians and
dehumanize ukrainians one that becomes
more cynical and more maniacal with
every bomb that falls in this
multi-ethnic and democratic country with
a jewish president whose family fought
and died in world war ii when the real
nazis invaded ukrainian territory
during an air raid we stumble upon one
of the happiest underground bunkers in
odessa
where we meet aid coordinator nikolai
nitiansky i'm looking around here you
don't look like nazis
so okay i'm jewish
what do you think is it possible to be a
jewish nazist
it's impossible at least hitler admitted
the jews exist he says putin says we
ukrainians do not putin says
that ukrainian nation is not exist
they
don't allow us to be
ourselves to have our identity as
ukrainians
for cbs saturday morning chris livesay
odessa